it felt like Washington itself might
become like Berlin during the Cold War
surrounded by enemies and perhaps even
fall to them so it was it was it was a
harrowing moment in the city's history
and that is that as the backdrop to the
story hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason
TV today we're talking with John Jay
Miller author of the historical novel
the first assassin give us the one
sentence summary its historical novel
takes place in 1861 Washington about an
assassin who has been hired to murder
President Lincoln okay and can you tell
us who did it or should we read the book
you can read the book although the
assassin is identified early on we
follow him around the city what drew you
to this material I'm a Civil War buff
I've grown up reading this stuff I enjoy
that error of our history i'm also a fan
of thrillers they're great pieces of
entertainment they tell great stories
and i had the idea of combining the two
and and and and for years I had the
notion of this particular idea now you
have I mean you're a well-established
well-known journalist hopefully not much
fiction in your journalism but what you
know why did you decide to become a
novelist I'm I'm an English major and my
inner English major I was always wanted
to write fiction of course I write
nonfiction professionally that's what I
do for a living but this has been a goal
of mine for many many years and I
started working on this book 13 years
ago and it was the project I kept
putting aside when when paychecks are
opportunities for them would come along
or children were born but but this this
was always there in the background what
was the strangest thing that you learned
about mid century mid-nineteenth century
DC it was a really business this as a
rich book I mean it really goes through
what it's like to be in that time
employees well I tried to make it as
historically accurate as possible a lot
of research one in the book to make the
city come alive so that readers would
understand what it was like with the
unpaved streets the unfinished Capitol
dome what Washington was like in that
era but the most interesting thing that
then provide
the backdrop for the book is how
harrowing it would have been to lived in
the city in 1861 when the country was
being torn apart when there were rumors
of conspiracies about bombing the
capital about murdering Lincoln fears
that the Virginia militia would come
across the river and take over the city
because there weren't enough federal
troops here to defend it and there were
there were several months when Fort
Sumter was falling when it felt like
Washington itself might become like
Berlin during the Cold War surrounded by
enemies and perhaps even fall to them so
it was it was it was a harrowing moment
the city's history and that is that as
the backdrop to the story talk a little
bit Lincoln is you know clearly the
great mythopoetic figure in American
history we keep moving back towards him
or speak through him some people love
him some people hate him what's your
basic take on Lincoln him why do you
think he is such a vast hole that a
tight grip on our imagination well he is
obviously the central figure in the
great drama of our national life and
he's a complicated man he's a great
character with a great story and and
there are many many opinions about him I
personally admire him I view him as a
champion of human freedom let's not
forget what it one of his great
accomplishments was ending slavery and
he kept the Union together who knows
what North America would be like today
if that effort had failed there are
criticisms of him anybody's flawed I can
make them myself but I think God mold
there's that yeah yeah funny looking guy
too he looks like a caricature so he's
fascinating to write about but but I
count myself as an admirer and he is a
he is a figure in the book yeah I'm talk
a little bit about how your publishing
this this is an interesting experiment
and do-it-yourself culture exactly I my
original approach was to sell it to a
mainstream New York publisher I've done
that before and when I finished the
manuscript I gave it to my agent New
York he's a very good agent who sold
books for me to Doubleday to harper
collins and so forth non-fiction books
and asked him to sell this one well he
tried and he couldn't and it turns out
that first-time novelists have a hard
time getting contracts especially when
the economy is as bad as it is
just wasn't anybody willing to take a
chance so last spring I was considering
my options I had not completely
exhausted them in that field but I
thought to myself you know I really do I
want to spend another six months or a
year struggling and possibly failing or
don't want to try something else I
started looking into self publishing and
I realized that self-publishing is not
what it used to be or at least my mental
image of what it used to be which is
little old ladies who write books of bad
poetry that nobody wants to read it's
actually a new entrepreneurial business
that the online resources have have made
available so I partnered with a company
called create space which is a
subsidiary of Amazon and it's a print on
demand service you basically upload your
PDF file and when someone buys a copy of
the book they will mail it to him and it
is I mean one of the things that we were
talking about this it's I mean it's
incredibly well designed and well put
together so it's not you know and I'm
not saying oh this isn't real but it's I
mean this looks as good as any book that
you're going to thought well thank you
and that was one of my goal I said if
I'm going to do this I don't want to
look homemade what are your what are
your goals do you have sales goals or
review goals or anything like well my
original goal was to have you know the
million copy lay down on the front table
of borders to be on Oprah and all that
stuff and that's still there in the back
of my head but right my immediate goal
when I was reassessing last spring was
just to get the book out to let people
enjoy it and and and and then now to go
into a phase where I try and tell as
many people as possible about I think
it's a good book that a lot of people
will like well well they kind of
publishing institutions things like
bookstores would they buy copies or
publishers weekly will they comment on
it and things like that it's all
possible and but as you can imagine
there's there's there's a there's a bias
built-in against this kind of thing and
it's a reasonable bias I get it they
trust mainstream publishers to serve as
gatekeepers so I need to overcome some
of that and I'm trying to and trying to
explain to people that there are old
ways of doing things and new ways of
doing now this is I mean it let's close
with a brief discussion of the politics
of you right for national work
you the Wall Street Journal you're from
the conservative end of things you're
doing something very innovative here do
the conservatives in the country needs
to start innovating and trying to start
new things well I'm an advocate of
entrepreneurship of free markets and so
forth and Nick I'm a conservative but as
you know when conservatives gather them
off I'm often the most libertarian guy
in the room this is this is a great
entrepreneurial venture I'm excited
about it I'm looking forward to it i
hope it succeeds do what what it what's
the one thing that conservatives need to
do to get back some kind of ideological
or elect electoral mojo i think what
they did in virginia is a good example
have a good candidate with a good
message that applies conservative
principles to the problems of right now
whether they are fiscal sanity or
transportation issues think about
conservative solutions which are often
free market solutions to our public
policy dilandau I know it reason we're
excited about him selling off the state
of liquor stores the last bastion of
socialism and the Old Dominion what's
your next project well i'm at work on
another book right now it is a piece of
nonfiction that's going to involve
history and sports and politics and i'm
also still working for National Review
and writing for The Wall Street Journal
and trying to keep as busy as possible I
want to thank Jon Jay Miller for talking
to us today about his historical novel
the first assassin thanks for coming in
John thanks